[Musique]
décidément la tragique affaire autour de
loana n'en finit pas de vivre de
nouveaux rebondissements
après les différentes accusations de
l'entourage de loana à l'encontre de
sylvie ortega voilà qui hier c'est loana
elle même qui prenait pour la toute
première fois la parole depuis son
hospitalisation dans une vidéo désignant
clairement sylvie ortega comme
responsable
jeannette apprennent rock des vapeurs
d'alcool ce sont des médicaments qui
m'ennuie dans le coma sur notre plateau
eryl prayer amis proches de loana se
faisait son porte-parole en amenant
d'autres éléments accablants contre
cette fameuse sylvie lui a fallu une
dose de médicaments alors qu'elle a
failli en mourir donc elle a quand même
pas mal de casseroles au cul
sylvie s'est pourtant toujours dit
proche de loana et nous vouloir que son
bien-être
alors sylvie ortega était responsable
des malheurs de loana selon vous ce soir
elle a décidé de répondre pour livrer en
direct sa version des faits donnée
merci sylvie théâtre avec nos sylvie
ortega et c'est vrai que s'il me cette
histoire elle est complètement folle est
bon passionne tous les soirs c'est
devenu un véritable feuilleton la sphère
loana irreal qui a eu des mots
extrêmement durs pour vous sur vous il
ya quand même il ya un jour et 24 heures
il sera avec nous en face de vous dans
un instant juste avant de donner la
parole à sylvie qui veut réagir déjà sur
cette affaire avant que je pose vraiment
les questions importantes si oui alors
oui normal c'était pendant une semaine à
miami avec loana j'ai partagé ma chambre
avec elle donc vraiment j'ai pu en une
semaine nous rendre compte c'était une
femme très très fragile et influençable
moi je pense pas que que tout soit de la
faute de sylvie mais je pense juste que
on ne peut pas délivrer un médicament
aussi puissants sans être un médecin
ça c'est une chose grave se trouvent
parce que c'est simplement parler qui
vit dans un instant louis gill moi je
voudrais redire à siviriez gars les yeux
dans les yeux ce que je pense
parce que c'est honnête de vous lire les
yeux dans les yeux je pense que vous
avez organisé ce qui est pour moi une
mise sous tutelle sans l'autorisation
administrative de loana et la tutrice
dans votre esprit c'est vous c'est que
vous avez organisé sa dépendance
médicamenteuse psychologique aujourd'hui
j'ai eu des tas de gens qui m'ont dit
que depuis septembre vous étiez arrangé
pour être seul vous avez fait le ménage
autour de loana parce que vous avez des
intérêts personnels financiers qui vous
regardent vous êtes impliqué c'est vrai
vous étiez là pour faire le ménage chez
elle le premier soir j'en suis témoin
ajouté au téléphone c'est vrai dans le
chum est là mais là vous avez mis loana
sous dépendance et c'est dangereux voilà
ceux du mans pas d'accord autres je vais
commencer par une chose alors jusqu'ici
quand je vais commencer par une chose ce
qui s'est passé hier soir est
extrêmement grave très grave je sais pas
si sur ce plateau
il ya quelqu'un qui est conscient de la
gravité de ce qui s'est passé hier soir
à savoir à savoir personne à penser si
j'avais une famille des enfants des
parents que quelqu'un pouvait être
cardiaque quand ma famille notamment ma
mère qui allume le poste télévision et
qui aurait pu tomber raide attendait
d'autre part personne n'a pensé à moi
qui suis seul
ok c'est mon choix d'être seule personne
parce que je suis quelqu'un de très
solides qui ouvre ma gueule et je
dérange et donc mais personne a pu
comprendre que peut-être que j'avais des
faiblesses et que j'aurais pu me
suicider et me balancer avec ce qui
s'est passé hier soir donc ce qui s'est
passé hier soir est très très grave
parce que via a conscience sur ce
plateau de ce qui s'est passé
et hier soir sylvie vous pensez à quoi
penser à l'intervention d'hier il met
enfin lui il a même pas enfin je ne sais
même pas tu veux relever la question
irrite on voit bien que c'est pas moi on
va voir les élus et le comité des
schtroumpfs excusez moi quand je vois
une loana qui l'a tout sourire je vais
excusez moi mais moi si on essaye de me
tuer je vais pas faire une vidéo tout
sourire en train de dire oui alors je
vais très bien non je suis traumatisé
son essaye de métier alors justement
pourquoi luana vous pros luan à vous on
veut pas si vous êtes il ya une semaine
dont vous étiez sa meilleure amie
déjà j'ai jamais dit que j'étais
s'améliore c'est une très bonne amie à
elle vous dit pas non mais c'est quoi
son ami alors cette loi n'a ça fait dix
ans que je la connais jean n'a pas les
mêmes fréquentation on n'a pas du tout
le même on n'est pas du même monde on
n'est pas du même milieu
par contre à chaque fois qu'elle a eu
des bobos ou des problèmes ou quelque
chose j'étais là en tant que psy à
l'écouté des heures et des heures et des
heures
ça c'est une chose je vois juste souvent
on va juste revoir eux ce qu'a dit voilà
on va on va voir une vidéo de loana dire
si vous les avez s'il vous plaît pas ce
qu'on va voir loana skate par contre je
tenais à rajouter à la tension de sylvie
que ma valise et étrangement vides ils
manquent de mes bijoux à vars aux as et
barda ump-udf émettant jusqu'à mi slip
j'en ai même plus une j'ai plus de
pilotes plus de fer à friser plus de
bijoux les plus rien dans ma valise
la réal est vide une valise vide
étrangement et tu étais 7 kg était à
côté de moi dans la chambre d'hôtel
je vais porter plainte aussi pour vol de
tous mes bijoux parce qu'il m'a appris
dans ma valise
alors oui endroits ce qui s'est passé
alors on voit bien qu'on a quand même
affaire à quelqu'un qui est soi-disant
qui vient d'être qu'on a voulu tuer mais
on voit une femme total totalement
normal qui à sa tête on voit qu'elle est
pas net
mais on voit quand même que c'est ce
qu'elle dit qu'elle est sous l'emprise
deux personnes jusqu'ici lui est lancé
pour nom mais vous accuse de quelque
chose d'aussi grave vous a plu de
quelque chose de tout le monde de quoi
vous attendez venue sur le plateau en
disant qu'on lui avait volé ses huit
cent mille euros
sa mère et fred vous étiez d'accord avec
lui elle était là j'ai jamais dis oui
encore lui avait pas dit non je n'ai
rien dit du tout sur le suppo ni
prononcé oui mais non mais vous jamais
soi disant voilà non je n'ai pas dit non
c'est pas mon rôle de dire aujourd'hui
je vous accuse elle fait des accusations
très graves contre vous l accusé
plusieurs alors j'ai dans mon portable
damman elle a accusé eryl aussi deux
meilleures amies qui va venir dans un
meilleur ami son meilleur ami
voilà le pied le king des schtroumpfs
qui chante t love me tender voilà sur
les marches de cannes sans qu'il y ait
personne un hockey à qui lui est lui a
foutu des casseroles et c'est un homme
qui manque de classe qui est là en train
d'insulter une femme une femme je suis
désolé à la limite calkins am insulte à
mr damas quelque chose comme ça à un
homme
ok mais un homme est ce que vous l'avez
l'annoncé ça on va revenir là dessus
est ce que vous ne voulez même pas du
chien est ce que vous lui avez donné des
médicaments comme elle dit de granace de
temesta 2 imovane à la déjà alors avant
de ça c'est dommage qu'ils aient pas un
médecin sur le caillou il peut venir
voyage pas s'arrêter là
aucun mail a dû me venir ou pas oui mais
j'espère qu'il avait aussi beaucoup
espèrent qui va venir
donc quelqu'un à qui j'aurais
administrés quand bien même je dis quand
bien même quand bien même j'aurais
administrés de temesta de xanax deuxième
aux vans personne ne peut faire un coma
et mourir avec ça ok travers d'autre
part je lui ai donné la veille
on ne parle pas le jour de son délire 1
la veille je lui administrer parce
qu'elle faisait une crise de tkm terme
dit jacky canosi anti-chars dire est
qu'elle était enceinte et anime la
turquie car disent ils voient enfin bref
sur une crise d'angoissé
donc elle avait pu de plaquettes elle
avait plus rien du tout façon elle est
partie sans son traitement à savoir les
papilles bipolaire du tout comme elle a
menti quand elle est venue
non donc elle ment en fait quant à lui
dit qu'elle se drogue pas et on est dans
les îles personnellement constamment moi
je moi loana loana c'est quelqu'un que
j'avais de l'affection
parce que parce que elle faisait peine
quand elle me dit qu'elle est cette
phalange de change de sujet je finis
charline obligeait des médicaments donc
effectivement la veille
elle est bien à savoir que je connais
pas que toutes les deux sur le tournage
on est quand même cinq personnes de
confiance
on est cinq personnes je ne suis pas
seul à tourner je ne suis pas là en
mission à vélo anna en train de me taper
un week-end entre copines
pas du tout on est là pour un travail au
quai pascal a pas une étude est qu'elle
me demande de lui trouver des contrats
chose faite
ok d'accord très bien donc
d'autre part la veille je dis bien la
veille elle fait une crise d'angoissé
un bon ok très bien je lui donne
effectivement de xanax de 0,25 ce qui
fait qu'ils vont 1,05 par bien changé de
cible parce que vous avez toujours été
critiqué par beaucoup de personnes
notamment certaines personnes de
l'entourage de l'anah ce qui semble
avoir changé c'est votre relation avec
le wanna live vous êtes servent de
choses concrètes
qu'est ce que vous avez à lui répondre
et ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui a
changé dans notre relation est là elle
en boule par mme sur cette histoire de
bijoux vous lui auriez volée qu'est ce
que vous avez à lui répondre est ce que
c'est vrai ou pas et s'il ya quelque
chose qu'il ya eu une césure entre vous
et loana est pourquoi alors pas vu de
c'est à dire que loana est une fille qui
sait très bien ce qu'elle fait très très
bien 1
elle est très manipulatrice je pense
qu'on ait beaucoup de victimes
ça te fait rire non mais n'empêche que
vous avez raison de vous marrer passé
des choses qui sont quand même pas très
drôle
c'est très très drôle parce que quand on
parle et manipulatrice me sens capable
de les piloter de machin est rude
est ce que c'est vrai que vous l'avez
voler ses bijoux par exemple mais qu'est
ce qu'elle va mais pas question de ne
parler pas vous intéresser
c'est quoi cette histoire de réduire
jouent alors je vous explique comment ça
s'est passé
davy chaud on est toujours sans
qu'évidemment on est toujours 5 évident
on est 5 jusqu'au tournage à l'été
nourris entre mais c'est une histoire
vise à la fouille accueil qui a posté
une photo vidéo et mais si je me suis
plié par l'egypte ironique quand même à
savoir cas d'accès à la clinique donc
quand on l'emmène et a pas que moi il ya
le chauffeur avec moi je suis pas tout
seul à pied sur une trottinette en train
de me prendre mais avec une avalanche de
l'autre on est d'accord ça va mais
ouvrez tous les yeux soyez du sida font
même pas une chose on n'est pas obligé
d'aimer tout le monde mais bon voilà on
voulait pas un verre d'eau on est avec
moi je veux bien faire de même surtout
pas le douaisis sans merci beaucoup à
faire mais si vous êtes sur tf1 merci
alors douala donc on y plusieurs
évidemment je me trouve avec la chose tu
as trouvé avec la valise en carton là
jeudi il y avait il ya le petit
producteur news avec nous très mignon
très bien on a été aussi une option leur
isolement mais je me je n'en attendais
je veux pas finir aussi non
fonctionnement il y avait cinq par nice
et enfermant nus ou top avec un peu
mieux c'est super encadrée depuis un
super encadré dont je me retrouve avec
une à l'hosto qui accuse deux des
membres à temps même s'il y attend même
ce soir là il ya quand même elles mêmes
et de se marrer il ya quand même ce soir
là la face de l'hôtel à pied à la file
shoot ou des demi heure le le comment ça
s'appelle le possible chauffeur c'est la
celtie de la nuit moi qui la ramène
il pleut alors on a on a des chambres
que usa
jardins jardin palerme mattia walt est
chez elle dans enfin dans sa chambre
alors s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
yair il ya donc hélas parfois faire
enterrer les bons il est bon il est
risqué l'accueil des montres travaux
hier merci d'être là le scanner sur un
plateau et qui insulte une femme moi
j'appelle pas ça un homme
personnellement et un homme c'est bien
leur nom
c'est très beau un homme qui parle de
moi je bloque à moi j'adore rigoler mal
à manger une annonce à faire c'est vrai
qu'on attend d'un temps de latence et
moi qui ai la parole pour l'instant tu
te tais tu vas te calmes et non c'est
une blague
s'il tient à reconnaître tu es tu prête
avec tout pourquoi sylvie laisser le
personnel est très ronde aurait dit un
tribunal où le thème vivez vous il
arrive pile me fait ça soit encore
valable compris tout le monde et montre
cela et mettre son portable on peut pas
de mon pêcheur et montres jean basset
foi qui est risible
il montre son portable comme ça en
pleurant
il est beau il est beau il est bon thé
risible et larmes très mal entouré
entrée libre sur son compte personnel où
j'ai fait péter les followers
tu as fait tomber tes lunettes ça ne
regarde pas alors nathalie la tombe et
aplatit reprendrons notre sérieux en
quoi notre calme alors émis qu'est-ce
qui se passe bon alors tout d'abord je
tiens à reconnaître que je me suis
emporté dans votre émission et que ce
n'est pas ma façon d laver son nom mais
il a un truc à dire où est passée la
culotte a cédé 2 loana
voilà on va laisser le temps de guerre
j'amène pas dans ma patrie lui dire je
reprends cas oui d'abord je tiens à
reconnaître que je me suis emporté dans
votre émission et que ce n'est pas ma
façon d'être
ni mon éducation de motivation copé mais
j'étais très proche de mon père est de
savoir qu'une personne comme elle
qu'elle se dénigrer ma famille et tout
particulièrement mon père qui est décédé
en 2013 en utilisant les réseaux sociaux
m'a été insupportable
je pense que beaucoup d'entre vous qui
ont le respect de la famille peuvent me
comprendre tout le monde pleure regarde
avait précisé si mal non je souhaiterais
récupérer les affaires de loana à ses
bijoux et les cartes de crédit pas tout
ce que tu as bellegarde et grédy gimb
l'âge que je puisse les lui rendre
le dernier message à transmettre de luan
à l'ohada aimerait que tu désactive le
comte tik tok tu as créé à son nom alors
là vous répondra
[Musique]
c'est la position et même les cas
maintenant leur merci quant à moi j'ai
fait de mon mieux que des lois na waie
en ayant ces informations car elle était
qui ont la capacité de le faire
t'as même pas voulu du germe évidemment
c'est bon ça peut toujours compter sur
mon soutien et sauf si elle me le
demande je n'ai plus de messages à
transmettre de sa part je tiens à
remercier monsieur cyril hanouna et la
production de thé prévenu pour avoir
donné par mon intermédiaire la parole à
loana pour qu'elle puisse se défendre et
bien évidemment je remercie les nombreux
internautes pour leur soutien est ce que
je voudrais dire c'est que moi le rona
ça fait plus de dix ans qu'on est amis
on s'est engueulés loana et moi on s'est
aussi frites et je suis vu qu'on sait
qu'on s'effrite et mais pas content ya
une chose que moi je n'ai jamais fait la
victime et d'argent ça monte moyen de
choses que je n'ai jamais été avec loana
seville et c'est de finir qu'on a qu'on
n'est pas gêné c'est fini on sait que
discuter du ressenti on a défoncé frites
et voilà c'est pourquoi on vous disant
ennemi monde est toujours amis au bar
est surtout quel traité de con il n'ya
pas longtemps à ce que moi en rapport à
toi où est ton ami fred commun voilà je
n'ai jamais traité dans la boue comme
vous faites dans les à m
jamais traité dans la boue comme toi tu
fais avec fred corral oui non les
réseaux sociaux je n'ai plus à parler à
cette personne juste sylvie qu'est ce
que vous allez faire maintenant après
ces accusations de wana vous allez faire
quoi c'est quoi qu'est ce que vous allez
faire je vais faire le nécessaire avec
mes avocats qu'on est déjà sur la sphère
sur deux à faire exactement
et puis voilà et puis et puis ça sera
fait de toute façon l'erreur est qu'ils
ont fait et qui nous a bien rendu
service d'ailleurs c'est de voir qu'on a
deux personnes complètement logiquement
c'est à dire n'être fadesa d'esprit
puisque elle peut parler tout seul sans
personne à côté
et voilà donc déjà c'est pas bon pour
elle et on voit bien quand même qu'elle
ait pas d'alcool départ mais bon non
plus là bas très nette non plus on
comprend rien aucune balle et les
dernières phrases j'ai rien compris à ce
que vous disiez avait pas ce que
peut-être que voilà je sais pas mais à
vous allez porter plainte ou pas ces
croquis allait porter plainte mais les
contres qui est sur quel fondement ce
qu'elles font oui et contre qui mais
même à ce que notre une personne qui dit
comme ça que j'ai voulu là dessus et
contre quelqu'un qui qui qui qui
cautionnent ça est assez qui s'est
d'abord vous porter plainte contre loana
c'est ça loana et ribéry la justice il
vit juste pour on parle pas de justice
est ce que ça vous a fait de la peine
la vidéo qui a fait loi parce que ça
vous a touché ce nom je vais été étonné
à celle chez vote c'est votre ami vous
étiez va le dire vous me disiez présente
pour est ce que ça vous a fait de la
peine ce que ça vous attend non parce
que j'ai pas été très étonné pour la
bonne raison que le 15 février
loana donc elle devait déménager est bon
je devais l'aider à son déménagement
parce qu'il y avait personne qu'ils
aient des bennes normalement maintenant
le même plus il est des vérités canigou
pas et donc est trouvé un appart airbnb
voilà pas que je reçois sur mon
téléphone et j'ai la preuve vous leur
envoyez d'ailleurs je reçois les les
codes d'airbnb bon après me dis comme ça
devant moi ta carte d'identité je
comprends pas et quand je parle à
secouer je lui dis on m'a volé ma carte
d'identité
bon entre temps je rappelle quand même
gmail ouanna qu'est-ce que tu es en
train de faire là elle me dit que je
ferais un bébé belge ctb ok d'accord
mes amis mais tu comprends bien que j'ai
pas de sous bagis oui ça j'en suis
consciente mais pourquoi tu me demande
ma carte d'identité à la tienne conforme
pas en eux voilà donc voilà devant nous
alors déjà là j'ai eu des soupçons juste
il vit
viril moi j'ai une dernière question
pour vous deux vous avez pas juste envie
que d'une chose c'est que loana a de
mieux et que vous soyez tranquille et
que vous puissiez retrouver votre ami
comme à la traîne maintenant oui pour ma
part oui ce n'est plus mon problème
vous êtes en vie devant moi je vais vous
dire quelque chose cyril à je vais vous
dire quelque chose
voilà pendant qu'il y en a qui se
crêpent le chignon
c'est vrai que des fois on va un petit
peu loin mais pendant que quelqu'un se
crêpent le chignon ou quoi moi c'est
vrai que j'ai un caractère volcanique ça
c'est une certitude
un bon c'est bien qu'il ya plus grave
dans la vie ça mettrait tous oui et à
savoir que pendant qu'il y en a qui font
j'ai des tonnes de follower machin truc
et cetera mois pendant ce temps là je
suis en train de faire de la littérature
donne aux hôpitaux à des enfants
auraient été rémunérés quand même pour
le travail de l'om a refait donc là
enfin le lien c'était bien aussi si je
voulais prévu de dire comme ça que moi
je suis là avec des enfants qui sont
quand même en soins palliatifs en train
de leur sert la lecture pendant que
certains ils sont là en train de pleurer
sur des plateaux et après montrer à mes
followers ont augmenté je sais vous
plaît allez hop
merci sylvie en tout cas devant m6 à
vous